hey guys we've both been on Conan and
intoxicated on live television we're
gonna do it right now again welcome to
impaired this former teen idol turned
comedian Greg daughter has been blazing
across America being a part of the
oddball comedy tour
you see on MTV's judgment a friend from
the widest ways in touch
eleven stones and nine men he's been a
part of the Attleboro Comedy Festival
but it's currently writing for Jim
Jeffries show his hair is so goddamn
ready
the Tata my crap they give the next
prime minister from No let's go job
let's welcome
[Music]
okay we're here and we are having a good
time
already welcome our guest Jay Jay and
grant everybody thank you
[ __ ] yeah how you guys doing pretty good
man
pretty good pretty good smoke it a
little wave of the drags I'm joining up
so far I'm already high and I'm 2
Twinkies deep and I see a third one on
the horizon hate him I can't touch the
thing why they're delicious well I don't
know what delicious but they don't taste
delicious I know it's bad guys sacrilege
but but apparently they could survive
the apocalypse people say he's thinking
cockroaches but I think that's [ __ ]
I don't buy into that well that's way to
say survive diabetes are here later
there's all you need those Twinkies I
just don't buy the Twinkies everything
that's left well you gotta get into it
man you gotta believe there's a lot like
more important like very poor in life
and that fight for dying on this hill I
will die on every ok it tastes like the
apocalypse authority on it's already
stale no no they don't get stuff that's
the point I'm gonna dive into this no
every episode we have a secret word that
if somebody says it we're gonna hear
this and then everybody will drink or
smoke and then actually last episode is
the first episode that we've ever done
where somebody didn't get it does it not
happen we never hid the secret word so
can we find out what that secret word
was now you cheat the system and
somebody still didn't get it they say
we're really happy that the bar
husband said that low 20 every system
hopes for this I think we're gonna get
it Twinkie Twinkie
you know we'll start with shot me a jet
you're gonna take wouldn't arianism well
take an enormous show cheers gang close
to it episodes pretty good that
delicious pretty good though not boring
no you didn't like it's tasty tequila
tequila like a splash of cran a splash
of ginger ale and then a splash of
simple syrup
I call that shot jacy's drunk and just
throwing things into a glass so if you
want to make that one at home it's a
good one
sounds like it would cost 1495 at a bar
it would cost more than that and I have
how did you get it with a I mean also
the shots I poured for us were at least
doubles it's a recipe on their website
just listen and listen well or you're
[ __ ] or that's a coffee you just slam
him Chris now tell me about what I'm
smoking in this pen well that is a
disposable pen not my favorite the pens
and uh we prefer to smoke when we do
smoke pens on the show our bonsai babes
cuz they are nice enough to donate to
the show when I'm smoking this is
Skywalker og the winner of the BYOB cost
segment the end the show will get a
Snoop Dogg og oh hell yeah sick product
place man
I think Snoop Dogg would do anything you
want for like five thousand bucks you
could get him on this show I'd like to
say like five grand he could smoke weed
okay like Alice cobby grant you're oh
you're way over extending what our
budget is well let's do a Kickstarter
guys
link below to subscribe to the cation
this [ __ ] show grants also doing a
trend that we've had with every episode
which is the guests are better host than
me as a constant for a hot shrew yeah
man I haven't made you a drink
you gonna make me what you're a great
host thanks bud you want to jump into
our first game I love this game it's our
first cent playing it it's very stuff
it's called drink the rest of whatever
was in a shaker you guys will love it
too I'm the only one with the answers
god preserve over Florida and it's a
little game I like to call man from
Florida or Florida man or wild animal
I'm gonna read you a headline I'm gonna
say in the headline I'll say blank and
that is either a wild animal or a man
from Florida all right all right ready
to rock okay feeling it all right let's
start with the first one ready everyone
take their answers and we'll figure it
out contractor left bloody after blank
attack Chris I almost a Florida man
Florida man I'm gonna say animal on that
one because it edible yeah I think is a
self-induced
a nail gun wound okay I want to say I'm
going with alligator alligator in a pool
the answer is a wild animal it's a wild
animal gang it's a cougar the contractor
same time I didn't read that far I only
got the headlines because I did the
research on this normally Chris Koch
does our research and it's terrible but
but I felt that I should do as bad a job
as he there's more of it that's true
I've been proven right you guys if you
donate to our Kickstarter at the $100
mark you can find out if the contractor
lived or died
subscribe to our channel click the link
below if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up already kill it it Alaskan man
mauled by blank ex-wife human I'm gonna
say Cuban on bath salts all right so
it's Florida man polar bear polar bear
oh but that didn't happen in Florida no
it didn't have any mo just happen in the
world right all of them just happen in
the world not a lot of polar bears in
Florida that's true right chaos ensues
after Blanc escapes in crowd of tourists
6 injured
oh I'm also gonna go with Cuban on bath
salts for this one too
[Laughter]
he escaped I don't I didn't again and
bring the articles I just got the
headlines I think I remember this story
he escaped from Costco and got a wildest
[ __ ] attack six people all right we
can cuz yeah curse all you [ __ ] one
yeah
PCP involved in blank attack I'm gonna
wild animal but animal got ahold of some
angel dust said some [ __ ] right I like
it I want to go with animal on this one
too cuz it just seems like a fun Disney
movie gone wrong
I keep getting them wrong animal I'm
gonna stick with my system you know it's
feeling a bamboo PCB involved in baboon
a jack
involved in baboon attack from when I
ran up the graph of the article PCP and
then went to the zoo and already could
find a monkey why would you try to fight
the animal that's most like you I love I
love every time he said baboon I was
like if he doesn't say that Boone the
actual bird answered I'm gonna lose my
[ __ ] life
Trump supporter attacked by blank at
rally Trump supporter well it can't be a
school animal because all Florida men
voted for Trump and it can't be a baboon
because that answer has been sent five
times in one time so what I got repeat
it again
so it's Trump supporter attacked by
blank at rally owl love it
probably [ __ ] I might as well
Eagle Eagle no Trump supporter attacked
by Florida man he was a film that's why
he couldn't vote he was jealous like I
walked round I mean they hi voted for
him that's why he's upset as he wanted
to I thought that was a good curveball
because I felt like my Florida people
are so there's you got us yeah blank
breaks into home and devours fridge of
steaks Oh blank home was that Kristen
devours fridge of snakes
oh what a ding put him in there a thong
and they already follow he's like I am a
come home and cook these steaks right
I'm gonna say that was an ant
coz a human would have some more [ __ ]
self-respond he well it doesn't say if
you cook the steaks afterwards not I
mean cuz I guess that would give it away
what gives that were an alligator that
cooked the steaks afterwards I go with
animal and well yeah it's gonna be an
animal of some sort I'd say but I can't
think of can't think of everyone
I don't know Florida everyone's wrong on
this one Florida man breaks into home
and devours fridge of stays at Rip Torn
[Laughter]
in Chris together that's why you need a
home and see the dude sitting on your
couch all bloated and [ __ ] mapped out
from 50 rippings are just ripping
through steaks we're gonna get back into
gary
cuz raw steak beef tartare it's
expensive right we got to we got our
final one I'm gonna choose between the
two I have all right there we go ready
for the Sheriff's Department on high
alert after Blanc attacks kindergarten
classroom this sounds the most Florida
man eaten wild animal Chris I'm gonna
say alligator Florida man Florida man
hedge hog on PCP I'm tryna PCP and the
winner and the winner of the entire game
is Greg Connor everybody there's a
Florida man
[Applause]
high alert after Florida man attacks
kindergarten classroom it didn't get
accepted man I was like I can't handle
this anymore
and I want to fight these children my
kids homework you are divided [ __ ] them
all BAM Boone sounds Wilders that
compare new punch line after every joke
BAM boom hey dude he's the [ __ ] man no
enjoying this too much that's the whole
point of the [ __ ] show go bring us
into the next game of it the next fun
thing it's just a segment of our fun
stories wrong in itself I'm not getting
[ __ ] up usually I started off with
since I introduced this segment JC why
don't you lead us off I got you all
right wash your hands right now but why
don't you explain the whole the game
first up they're just telling stories
just okay all right guys we're gonna
we're Nate we're all gonna tell a story
about getting [ __ ] up where maybe it
went crazy or well you know some
something occurred and it went it went
off it went off hand so now that it's
lame guys right now we're just gonna
tell a story about when we got [ __ ]
you said none of the things Chris cope
is a horrible host I'm a terrible host
as well but you guys how about a round
of applause for our host tonight if they
came all the way out here for just being
in the show you know you're great guest
Chris has an upcoming comedy album
coming out so please like the Winx
subscribe it's called sometimes I know
what's happening so I am I'm a drunk we
were very we don't share stories I am so
I went to a bar with a group of buddies
and I got aggressively drunk and someone
who looked my buddies all look the same
in my brain someone ordered a round of
shots at the bar and they looked like my
friend so being an [ __ ] I was gonna
walk up and take as many of the shots as
I could without them seen that I'd done
it
that's Jay Jay so I someone in order to
round a like-for-like you eat bro you
like [ __ ] projected it consumes the
cut to God days it's caught a light
it'll stay rude with sewer water and the
gutters of Tijuana it'll stay in there
that day do we have to have Tecate for
when water won't do what the swap meet
secondo sure it is war Vicky's
[ __ ] for that third extant this
stranger had ordered a round of shots
I walked up as he turned to try and
start passing them to people in order to
run a five shots I think and I walked up
and took three of them attack them
aggressively and then turned to him
thinking it was my buddy and went hi you
[ __ ] not what not what he was expecting
not so he turned around and went like
what the [ __ ]
tried to take a swing at me but I was
very intoxicated and in the AHA you [ __ ]
I had slipped and I fell backwards and I
landed on the floor so he swiped at me
taking a swing and it barely grazed my
nose but it was like the wind of his
hand knocked me out because when I hit
the floor I didn't get back hit the
floor and I was done I hit this slammed
into the floor and then I got kicked out
of the bar and I don't remember any of
us I was dragged outside by whatever
number of bouncers it took to get me
outside and then they put me into a car
my buddies and uber and I got back to my
apartment this was in Florida I'm not
living with this man and I got inside of
my apartment and I urinated on my
roommate thinking that his bedroom was
the bathroom I've done that were you
laying in bed with her I did and I went
and just pissed in her closet I walked
up to the edge of his bed I passed out
on the floor after I pissed on him and
my roommate dragged me outside of the
bedroom and he he dragged you outside he
dragged me outside of his bedroom and he
urinated on me in the living room oh
geez and I woke up and I was like what
happened and he's like he pissed on
yourself sleep some people didn't pay a
lot of money to have that done to them
so I got a discount yeah I was on the
road once my girlfriend's visiting me
and I got out of bed after a night of
drinking doing whatever with her and I
got out of bed and her suitcase is still
on the floor and I went over to the
suitcase and I scooped I remember
telling her this - oh I get there was a
suitcase and they scooped her clothes
out of the suitcase and then just kind
of squatted pissed right there in her
cigarettes and just pissing you piss man
I thought I was a wolf I thought it was
I was so sure I was a wolf
I couldn't see the lake I was taking
care of my pack
[ __ ] was cool I was like all right
ladies right there everything's safe and
I just woke up with her hitting me with
a pillow yelling what the [ __ ]
happening
[Laughter]
thank God she I mean I'm not with her
anymore but I phone iPod she called the
Peapod for the rest of the trip I think
she's now I'm thinking back I understand
why we broke up babe I'm sorry so loved
the fact that you were the one being
like everything's gonna be fine same
thing when they're shit-faced is always
the person I met aha right well I gotta
be honest I've never made [ __ ] VIN
peed on or piss on anything but you know
what if this episode gets wild JC you're
peeing on me tonight is it seven hundred
dollar mark on our Kickstarter you can
pee on me
750 Fiat me too hell yeah 800 pee on all
four of us let's take a Twinkie in our
ass and see if it fits right now so so
far as long as our episodes that were
gone it's grant grant and Lachlan are up
for best host right now it was [ __ ]
great and John - you guys are pretty
hard
yes yeah you know walk off your own City
Stories please comment you're right I do
have a story about DMT what a great host
Oh DMT we've had ayahuasca we'd have
acid mushrooms a lot of drinking stories
some weed stores but no DMT DMT was
weird cuz I'd always heard about it as
like EMTs and things like released in
your brain when you die so I thought it
was gonna be so [ __ ] insane it seems
terrified yeah that's like not a good
sales pitch for something I do drugs
like this happens right before you guys
wanna smoke [ __ ] die yeah you go okay
and so I was going to Joshua Tree we're
trying to get mushrooms from this dude
my friend goes in this guy's house and
it's like I'll be right back I'm getting
the mushrooms he's in there for like 35
minutes and then he he comes out to the
car he knocks on the windows like dude
you got to go in there with me this
guy's got DMT I'm gonna smoke it but I
need you to like watch because I'm
scared he's gonna touch my dick and I
was like what what did odd fear before
doing a very intense yeah exactly
but I was like what we guys doing alone
for 35 minutes in the first place just
kept whispering to a man if you want to
do DMT I'll touch your [ __ ] dudes you
want a discount you want to discount out
your [ __ ] dick if you go to sleep on
DMV so that he had a fear he had a
legitimate it's a legit fear he said it
to him so that's that's what he warned
me about so I go into this guy's
apartment it's actually super [ __ ]
nice like a lot of cool art everywhere
he had a mantle full of Emmys like he
did something in television and so then
I was like yeah come on down to the ATC
Network he had like where $1,000 in our
Kickstarter you can get your own show on
the network so DMT will pee on you and
give you a Twinkie for the apocatip it's
good that first year in Hollywood dudes
up so I'm in this guy's house
he's got the Emmys my homey sits on the
couch and this dudes like real holistic
like Buddhism like statues everywhere he
went he left and then it was just me and
my friend and living room was like this
guy's kind of weird huh yeah but he want
a bunch of enemies so like maybe like
maybe he's not that weird like maybe I
was thinking like maybe we could just
like touch his dick and then get like a
guest star on a TV show or something you
know I don't know Hollywood works
so I love it he leaves he leaves the
room he comes back two minutes later and
he puts on like a robe and you had like
a headband and you got like a real into
like this ceremony I thought you just
like smoked DMT and we're like I'm
[ __ ] up but like this will made my
friends sit on the couch like put these
like crystals down his body dude he
sounds like my first kind of died in a
Tarantino that's what he was trying to
healing before he did the DMT I was in
the right mind space so then he's like
he's you know my friend he smokes it he
lays down the guy's got like some
missiles and [ __ ] like bells he's ding
in putting him in this translucent state
and then my friend is totally fine for
like 10 minutes and then wakes up it was
like that was insane you have to do it
and the whole time I was like you didn't
see what the guy was doing to you who's
like going over your body like it's like
taking measurements visually like I
don't know what he was doing on what the
crystals were for so then nobody knows
I'm like alright I'll do it so he lays
me down they put the [ __ ] rocks on me
and he's doing the weird [ __ ] but I can
never fully get into it after I smoked
it because I go this weird dude in a
silk robe losing over yeah like he's
ringing the bell to near my dick for too
long like when he did it on my friend
like his whole body I don't know what
he's found my pH balance or some [ __ ]
then I had take the DMT and it's like
the whole world was treadmills like
everything I saw different like paths
and I went into this place and there was
like this big glacier iceberg with like
someone like Bjork and then I saw this
weird little court jester guy he was
just like like he was like trying to get
me to come somewhere and then I could
was like freaking out so I opened my eye
and then that's the end of the damn -
yeah when you open your eyes and you
just so busy yeah you're just like oh
that was it
my hands turn but it was like trying to
get you guys to go to some place and you
were like I'm dude I want to but like
there's a guy outside of this who wasn't
such a dick did you know what it was the
noid from Pizza Hut [ __ ] noise Little
Caesars not he had this that's Caesar as
Little Caesar at Little Caesars man he
like Papa John just has that creepy guy
with the white guy yeah Papa John all
nighters so DMT great explain it to him
DMT it was like a powder like he it was
like a weird little powder you know I
smoked that I have a pipe
he's a KB I might have done on top
subscribed as is the chemical that
releases in your brain when you die but
then I'm like how do they get it is it
in front of your brains yeah yeah it's
like some dudes I don't know we need a
fact check read oh yeah this is like
Chris Chris Thomas right he doesn't want
to do research got your show buddy
listen
what's DMT and if you know what it is
chemically tell us because we're
confused and grant did it and a man
tried to touch his dick he touched my
dick with a spiritual bell-to-bell and I
mean that in the most long way boss I
rang your chakra it was going but he had
Emmys like if everybody was gonna touch
my dick
no no my story the first time I got my
my ride lived with a foreign exchange
student for about six months
history China's name was ter and we got
along pretty much all the time
eyedropper but he uh they was what tear
he just that's how he pronounced it to
me I was like whoa I got your hair yeah
she's out there hmm
he uh when are we sharing it up I don't
know we stare at me like watch me legit
like an animal smoke weed cuz you've
never done it me it was always just like
and he really couldn't communicate and
ask questions his English [ __ ]
so he just would watch me and finally
like at the last like week before he
moved out I finally convinced him just
smoke do you remember that dragon
one-hitter I bought off you yeah this
thing was about this vague with a bowl
but the bull was [ __ ] huge I was
gonna Tufts by the time it was a
business steamroller one-handed I was in
college that I mean a lot of weird stuff
going on and it's tough it was really
tough and so I sold some of them glass
pieces that came to me for cheese goes
great so friends do so I pack a big-ass
[ __ ] bowl and we smoke it together
and he's just like I'm like are you high
he's like no I'm like what's wrong man
are you crying I just like I start
getting him high I've come on board
after the first Bowl I was like hey are
you feeling he's like no I was like okay
so I actually I packed up another fat
[ __ ] ball that thing smoked it with
him to the head and he just goes oh
racist no no that was cultural
appropriation he just literally all the
sudden went from I'm sober I'm fine - oh
[ __ ] yeah that's usually how it goes
it was just like oh what noise did he do
[Music]
with the eating chow mein afterwards
with the munchies he got from your drugs
we push into rugs on the Asians Chris no
this is what actually did for the best
of the night first off he goes to cook a
steak in the oven
puts the steak on a glass plate puts it
in the oven so 30 minutes later we're
sitting and the living room but it
sounds like a grenade goes off yeah I'm
like what happened he just goes oh no he
just goes oh no I'm like what I open the
thing there's glass they blowing through
the oven like blew the glass is like
melting and [ __ ] like the rest of the
night I hear him walk to the fridge open
it I was sitting on the couch I watching
me no but stare inside the fridge shut
it go back to the didn't 115 times never
took a single thing yeah welcome to my
life bro like you don't do that no I
usually I mean that's the most normal
thing in the story she a full-grown man
get that high and it was just such a
like mind bender for you man I got
[ __ ] up with him but it was an image
that it did just be I'm pissed that
[ __ ] baked a steak who's baking
steaks you can broil it [ __ ] boiling it
you got a flame grill that [ __ ] get the
nice little marks dude I worked at
[ __ ] olive garden salad what he did
it many he just it was just so funny
because I was like are you high yet no
and then it was like oh [ __ ] it just hit
him so fast and I saw his eyes focus
like I'm [ __ ] like that moment you
realize when you went from like I'm not
drunk to I've had 10 shots I think
that's the thing is and everybody like
it's smoking or drinking like there's a
moment where you go from like I'm trying
to get [ __ ] up as best I can
yeah well you're like working towards it
yeah go like the other problem is years
old registered he's never smoked weed
before so I kind of panicked I know my
first office [ __ ]
well agents have supple lungs so like
it's probably like Rick hit him in a
different way
[Applause]
and cameras that's weird
and why anyways three four so fun I'm
gonna jump into our one of our games
that we love we love this so much this
is my given different plan every time
and it's not a game he's coughing on me
he's sneezing on me what game is this
how can we get grant sick wait wait for
it wait wait wait we're gonna do it
we're gonna enjoy wasting we made an
item that you can make hammered or high
at your house with a bunch of weird
items that you could kind of like slam
into it like a really sweet and fun
treat this sounds great
that's what the guy with the Emmys told
me right before he started ringing about
what your ring ding dong ring ding ding
ding dong
[Music]
you
again we're back
yay and we're about to enjoy this
delicious treat that's been created
Chris explain what it is so this is the
organic churro
it is a banana they use a slattern
peanut butter and then you cover and
cinnamon toast crunch dust ctc for the
kids at home
[Applause]
[Music]
the cameras right now who's the [ __ ]
Cole cinnamon toast crunch
CTC this [ __ ] is not organic because
what kind of peanut butter is it
cinnamon toast crunch for sure is not
organic you need sure it's pretty
organic seriously bro I live in LA like
I used to work at Whole Foods like this
is my life knowledge don't even [ __ ]
with me another code for bananas is
everywhere you works at Olive Garden you
Whole Foods you notch this [ __ ] up bro
I'm like two weeks away from a a lyft
driver you think my career is like where
I wanted to be right now I have to work
I'm [ __ ] delicious by the way I
understand [ __ ] loser
god damn dog though yo you better go
ahead mark that [ __ ] right now
that's very good Elvis Presley would
love that [ __ ] I don't know why there's
four of them boy on each you have diving
in at different points we're fine yo
whoever eats a whole one right now just
banana to the face wins the [ __ ]
cartridge Chris go for it bro gives me
to eat all this in front of you naked
don't forget with the fifteen hundred
dollar donation you get to eat watch
Chris eat this naked get peed on
actually meet ter we're flying him back
from China to be a part of a very
I just choked on a [ __ ] banana dude
okay no half of that I'm like $1500 get
you all the things that Grant said
before he died and if you pay an extra
$200 you good to have grants dead body
delivered directly to your house and
then next week when JC plays the game
Florida man or animal the thing will be
somebody jump in with some possible to
try [ __ ] yo take it to the next level
let's bake it like the steak put it in
the oven in a glass plate and let's see
how wild we can get things here if the
plate explodes before this episodes over
you get a very special I would say it's
a medallion of Crisco being racist a
medallion what a nice way of saying
acutely racist look at my dad getting
color mistake I don't know like go look
at amulet raisin ambulant how dare you
take it just telling a story that
happened speaking of amulets when the
guy was waving the amulet over my dick
and I really felt the DMT hit me it was
a surreal experience much like it is
being on this show right now and I just
got to say that let's just skip to the
next segment where I asked JC to just
take a shot of Malibu straight out of
the bottle
oh god no don't do that bud okay we're
gonna jump to be healthy in just a
second no no you don't have to do that
this segment it was unsanctioned I
didn't run it by the producers so I
apologize you guys I'm sorry NBC I'm
sorry
CBS I'm sorry TBS I'm sorry c-span on
the Bible Network all right we'll be
right back we're gonna be on we're gonna
do BYOB next we'll see you soon no
performance from the Black Keys coming
up right
welcome back to impaired where this
segment we each make a different drink
for each other and see if we like it I
don't drink but Chris will drink double
for me and if Chris doesn't want to JC
he'll do it JJ how many are you gonna
have he was there it was good he didn't
do it rolling off so we're gonna jump in
all right gang gang Greg catchphrase
yeah
grant jump in again tell us about the so
big guys welcome to the grant Cotter
show today my guests are Chris coach JJ
Whitehead and JC curious curious curious
are you curious about it I'm curious
about it to this segment it's BYO
[ __ ] something
the last bartender thing oh there we go
yeah we're gonna get the name of the
cocktail and then a clue about said
cocktail everyone is gonna make that
beverage to the best of their ability
and then I'm in them give me back that
waiver I signed because he's sneezed on
me twice he's burped on me twice once
with Tecate once with Dos Equis which is
actually a lot worse than Scott
taillights be honest with you that was
directed in that direction you should
have felt that they sent a lift to pick
me up the guy had red locks and smelled
like weed you've listened to too much
Bob Marley redemption song on repeat and
then now granny okay can somebody get me
the guy with the Emmys look I need to
feel like I'm in a great place
you okay yeah I'm great okay but guys
welcome back to the show here we go take
five grant little breakdown Carter grant
great hold up bring us into this one
great have you guys accepted Jesus
Christ as your personal Lord here guys
the best game looking up is our favorite
game we're gonna play
it's called BYOB be your own bartender
they're gonna give us a clue and the
name of the drink and we're gonna have
to make it like JC said the best of our
abilities he will be the judge he will
he will know as you're judging on
basically how
I'm all about flavor Shawn I'm tasting
the cocktail and telling you guys
whether or not it can be sold at a bar
or people want to drink it because I
feel like I kind of know about that
stuff and then then how close is also a
winner based on who's closest to that
winner the winner of it gets a bonsai
vape brought to you by bonsai babes
thanks guys and I choose because I am
the lord of this segment man we get the
name of the beverage in our clue today's
beverage is a Long Island iced tea which
is known for having a much higher
alcohol concentration this concentration
than most highball yeah it's got like
everything you just said tonight's drink
is everything once we have 90 seconds
once they say go so we all gonna fight
for the same ten bottles
oh yeah quality matters quality does
matter I would drink them try to be
accurate monster about it now I have to
drink it anyway what's not monstrous I'm
not strong let me have your fifth
alcohol in grab you a coca-cola or back
dog is the competition dude you don't
watch chopped and then ask the other guy
for his salmon also congratulations guys
on hosting the show for the first time
that last segment I was really proud of
you guys it only took five [ __ ] takes
[ __ ] you great all right yo I'm pretty
cool you guys don't have ice tea isn't
there iced tea and Long Island iced
there certainly would not know where the
flavor is
wait is there Twinkie and Long Island
iced tea you want do you like Diet Coke
or coke he's spraying on me now take a
top off girl oh we're okay okay this is
my first day okay I was a server at
Olive Garden they didn't let me work in
the bar have a drinking problem
gentlemen
we've always done oh my god come on
scout buddy guys tell me what you got
okay this is what mine is it is a little
you're supposed to remember its
Tanqueray that vodka triple sec and
whatever the slug Aperol is I think it's
rubbing alcohol and then a little bit of
[ __ ] gave her a sip there bud this half
of this is 99 cent store alcohol what is
this club soda is a brand that got
discontinued in 84 I'm just like I mean
it it's wrong it's not terrible it's
fine it's wrong it's not a Long Island
iced tea it's also not not good tasting
great what we got but well I'll tell you
what it mine doesn't have is a Twinkie I
don't know what I put in it for sure
triple sec Dec you oppor triple sec you
know just like in the bottom of your
Grandpa's cabinet I probably I don't
know if I got three olives in there I
for sure had like Malibu rum and then
some of this [ __ ] and then I squeezed a
little lemon in it like a pretentious
mixologist and then I don't know and
cranberry maybe and maybe another
alcohol and I want you to try it you
don't even have to request that smell it
it smells how long was it a lovely
bouquet how long was it aged in the
barrel I think it was aged 10 seconds
look at the legs it's delicious it
tastes fantastic clearly not a Long
Island iced tea but at the same time why
clearly there's no iced tea to mix it
with there's not it's supposed to have
[Music]
coke that's where the darkness comes
shut the really yeah the more you know
like
it's actually very good great thank you
so much oh it's lovely do you think I
could put Sunday dreary change it looks
like a girl with a big floppy hat would
drink with that what is NZ tell me how
it looks some Cola yeah and so I closed
my eyes for like 10 seconds it looks
like at all I can't believe there's not
iced tea in it I don't [ __ ] hate it
it's like what am I thinking I like it a
lot and it's way closer to a Long Island
pretty muddy clothes I didn't have all
the right things so it's pretty good
everyone outs of humour if you may you
may try I am good well you're are you
gonna judge and taste your own you have
to have Chris do I'm doing it right now
yeah but they bias obviously you how do
I pass around everything yeah that is
actually pretty goddamn good vodka
tequila rum splash coke I put pineapple
in it the pineapple rum that's not it
shouldn't be in there as far as what an
actual Long Island is I was I'm
so I [ __ ] up as far as creating the
right one there should have been sour
mix because Sarah Mex should be in there
but is there sour mix and there is one
right I didn't put lime in I'm gonna try
I don't think it's gonna be JJ's judges
is great
so our Kickstarter My Mind's uh it's a
little thicker as far as I'm out of
booze please intelligence all right
let's hear what's in uh the Long Island
iced tea a Long Island iced tea is made
by mixing equal parts vodka gin rum and
triple sec topped with Cola and lime
juice I only missed a triple sec
honestly I gotta say this right now just
of general taste and how close you got
you just won the Banzai Snoop Dogg og in
the custom oak pen cartridge you two
could be doing weed with the youngins at
the playground this weekend thank you
guys so much I'm tuning in we really
appreciate it we'll catch you guys next
week where we have a bamboo nande the
Asian kid tear your pen and smoking yet
you've gotta buy the pen though sorry
[Laughter]
that's not true it's like the price is
right shut the [ __ ] up thing actually
you can buy bonsai babe cartridges on
the app let go from shady dudes with
tattoos on their face I've done it many
times and it's cheaper than going to the
stores the more you know apart - that's
funny
alright guys let us know where we can
find you I'm JJ white stink on Twitter
because I like to bait 80s rock fans and
yeah yeah it's Whitehead look Google
I love you for my new grant work we find
you I don't know if I want to tell
anybody to be honest with you like if
you guys can find me just like creeping
the streets you can find me at the skate
park smoking cigarettes with the youth
no you guys could just find me on
instagram or twitter at guys JJ
whiteheads debut this reached number two
on the charts ladies and gentlemen some
amazing stand-up little vampire comedian
jjy ahead you got to do two minutes now
yeah the worst Oh Joey
guys let's take it from the top
good it's a good video I didn't I should
have watched the full episode of the one
they sent me I watched the first three
minutes and everyone was laughing and
having a great time and then I realized
what happens during an episode of the
show this is worse than buyers are more
so we have volunteers everyone who is
crying or talking [ __ ] had a great time
no seriously guys time check the album
it's available probably through his
website he gave me this one he's gotta
find me out if you're gonna make a
goodwill inside Echo Park in about six
years I'm sure you're fun dog guys we
gotta get a new dog on the show
listeners viewers however your
shutting this if you know tell them to
give us a call the numbers right here
below let's check it out look we're like
a facility right here we got all the
best alcohol we're killing the game I
tunes go out pick it up modify there's
also that one Beyonce has if you have
t-mobile you guys guy put his clip on
snapchat two seconds at a time
that's how I like to digest it and I'll
share it with you guys follow me on apps
that are dead wire baby go really go
friend stuff search engine and folder
one hierarchy of holes cooking them I
just want to thank grant Connor JK
Whitehead coming by the car this hey you
guys glad you guys had fun yo I had a
[ __ ] blast there's so much having me
think you have me hosting not hosted by
me and Christmas tell your friends we're
looking for new house
[Music]